y yo les voy a contar sobre una historia
que creo que seguramente todos estamos
muy familiarizados los hombres y las
mujeres no vivimos la ciudad de la misma
manera y esto no es esto una verdad es
una realidad no es una percepción pero
ustedes se preguntarán y entonces cómo
es la vida de las mujeres alguna vez se
han preguntado si es que existe una
diferencia entre los hombres y las
mujeres en las pequeñas decisiones que
tomamos en el día a día
si no se han preguntado la respuesta es
sí y las diferencias son muchas y
empiezan desde que nos levantamos hasta
que nos acostamos por ejemplo la primera
diferencia es decidir que nos vamos a
poner y manga y no necesariamente porque
ese día el closets nos es insuficiente
que suele pasar con bastante con
bastante frecuencia al menos a mí sino
porque tenemos que saber qué vamos a
hacer ese día para decidir qué no usar
entonces si es que nos vamos a subir en
el bus no nos vamos a poner falda o no
nos vamos a poner vestido y entonces las
decisiones que nosotros tenemos que
tomar son frente a evadir las
situaciones de acoso sexual y los
hombres en cambio no tienen que hacer
entonces ellos se levantan se duchan por
en pantalones poner la camisa y salen a
hacer su día
y en ese tiempo ellos realmente no se
preguntan si es que la vestimenta que
escogieron va a ser un motivo para
sufrir una agresión sexual no les pasa
por la cabeza a nosotros así
y luego si el día ya salimos de la casa
tenemos que el trabajo o vamos a
estudiar o nos vamos a divertir y
tenemos que seguir tomando decisiones en
función de no ser acosadas entonces no
vamos a caminar por esa calle donde
hemos visto que hay una construcción y
si es que vemos que hay un grupo de
hombres bastante si estamos solas
entonces probablemente mejor vamos a
cruzar la calle nos vamos a ir por otro
lado y así seguimos tomando decisiones
justamente en función de no sufrir acoso
y claro nosotros también nos tenemos que
preocupar de los temas de seguridad y
también tenemos que cuidar la cartera
también tenemos que cuidar el celular
igual que los hombres es decir nosotros
también tenemos que tomar precauciones
en función de la seguridad pero aparte
de esas precauciones también tenemos que
tomar precauciones para no ser acosadas
para no ser tocadas para no ser violadas
para no ser matadas por el solo hecho de
ser mujeres por ninguna otra razón
y todas absolutamente todas dijimos son
todas prácticamente todas hemos sufrido
en algún momento en nuestras vidas un
caso de acoso sexual en las calles o en
los buses
puede que haya sido leve puede que haya
sido grave fue quiere decir una vez
puede que haya sido varias veces pero en
algún momento lo sufrimos
y en ese momento las cosas cambiaron
porque estamos en una sociedad en la que
el acoso sexual callejero de alguna
manera está como invisibilizado no es
cierto está co es como es como algo que
no no no no se debate nos discute y
entonces tenemos que pensar que es un
piropo tenemos que estar súper halagadas
porque nos dicen no no sí suspiro pues
nosotros somos bien galantes y no la
verdad es que nosotros lo único que
estamos haciendo es diciéndole lo bello
y lo hermosa que está hoy día pero
detrás de esa percepción hay una
realidad que tenemos que saber que
existe
y esa realidad es que el cuerpo y la
vida de las mujeres no es nuestra sino
que está a disposición de la sociedad
y entonces esa sociedad decide que si es
que nuestra falda está alta lo que
quiera que sea eso porque es tan
subjetivo o si es que el escote está muy
bajo o si es que el pantalón está muy
apretado entonces hay una razón
por la cual nos pasó algo ese día en la
ciudad o también la ciudad la ciudad la
sociedad decide que si es que una mujer
se pasó de copas o si es que salió sola
de noche entonces seguramente estaba
buscando
y digo esto porque esto de que el cuerpo
y la vida a las mujeres le pertenece a
la sociedad hace algunos años que es la
forma en que nos sentimos cuando este
tipo de cosas nos pasan hace algunos
años cuando yo todavía estaba estudiando
y ya estaba trabajando y tenía la suerte
de vivir cerca de mi trabajo un
privilegio que pocos personas pueden
tener en esta ciudad y claro que mejor
que trabajaba que ir caminando tu
trabajo porque claro no tienes que
subirte en el auto y estar en el estrés
del tráfico quiteño o no tienes que
subirte en el bus y tener que aguantar
el maltrato del mal servicio transporte
público que tenemos y entonces qué mejor
que poder caminar y claro yo feliz era
verano 8 la mañana caminando por la
avenida amazonas yendo a mi trabajo y
veía un hombre que se acercaba a mí y
pues estaba caminando igual que yo
seguramente estaba yendo a su trabajo
igual que yo
y cada vez que se acercaba estaba
demasiado cercano pero pues yo
honestamente no no sabía qué significaba
eso y cuando este hombre pasó al lado
mío
paso tocando de mis partes íntimas
y si yo
como que si nada había pasado como que
si esa era una rutina más en su día
salvo y voy tocando a las mujeres
y yo
me acuerdo ya habían pasado algunos años
pero la verdad es que la sensación
me quedé paralizada no sabía qué hacer
sinceramente me quedé helada me quedé
paralizada y me puse a llorar
y lloraba porque no entendía por qué esa
persona había decidido que podía tocarme
que podía tocar mi 4 mío
sólo yo puedo decidir a quien le doy ese
derecho
ese privilegio
y estas personas simplemente había
decidido que yo ya no tenía ese derecho
que ese derecho era de él
y me sentí como que no valía nada en
realidad
no era persona me sentí como un objeto
y a partir de eso las cosas cambian a
partir de esa primera experiencia a la
edad que tengas cuál sea leve o sea más
grave las cosas cambian entonces si
puedo ya no camino tarde que vamos
caminando mi vida
[Música]
nos toca decidir cambiar las rutas tal
vez algunas pueden decidirnos al
transporte público no todas pueden
entonces estamos doblemente expuestas y
claro como el acoso sexual callejero que
es esta
y forma de violencia es la principal
forma de violencia de las mujeres en el
espacio público es decir la violencia a
las mujeres ya no sólo está en el hogar
no está en el trabajo no solo está en el
trabajo está en lo público está en la
calle está en el bus está en la plaza
está en el parque está en estas
vivencias del día a día donde la ciudad
se supone que tiene que darte espacios
de convivencia no la ciudad se vuelve un
espacio agresivo
y ese espacio agresivo y esa esa
expresión de la violencia a las mujeres
en el espacio público es el acoso sexual
callejero porque qué es lo que hace
transformar la vida de las mujeres
entonces ya la ciudad no es la vida las
mujeres en la ciudad no es sobre
nuestras posibilidades y nuestros sueños
y querer vivir nuestra ciudad querer
disfrutar nuestra ciudad cuando salimos
sino que se vuelve a hacer que las
imposibilidades hace que lo que tenemos
que hacer para evadir ser acosadas hacer
que los nodos no usar falda nos al
vestido no salir muy de noche sola no
tomar el taxi sola no no no no no cuando
en realidad
si es que el acoso sexual callejero no
estuviera tan normalizado y no fuera un
tema de que es un halago es un piropo
o que es consecuencia de una decisión
que nosotros hemos tomado como es la
vestimenta entonces la así que las
mujeres no estaría construida alrededor
de evitar eso y alrededor de encontrar
maneras de evitarlo y además sobre todo
no estaría construido alrededor del
miedo y la desconfianza porque es lo que
nosotros pensamos esa mirada lasciva ese
ese roce ese piropo ese toque se va a
convertir en algo más se va a convertir
en una persecución en una violación en
un femicidio
y ese extraño en el bus que nos mira
mucho o esos pasos que escuchamos atrás
nuestro como muy cerca cuando estamos
regresando a la casa o ese hombre que
pasa en su auto y te pasa pitando y
diciendo algo tienes que preguntarte si
es que eso se va a convertir en algo más
imagínense
lo fatal y lo espantoso de vivir en una
ciudad en la que continuamente te estás
preguntando si es que te van a agredir
en la que continuamente estás tenemos
que cambiar tus decisiones y tomar
lecciones en función de no ser agredida
o más grave aún
en una ciudad en la que cualquier hombre
se puede convertir en una amenaza
qué feo tener que pensar que el otro
puede ser una potencial amenaza y qué
feo mi más frío de pensar que todo esto
está tan naturalizado y tan normalizado
que es parte del día a día que ya es
como lo normal no eso hay que hay que
vivirlo y es así
y
y yo estoy segura que ustedes no quieren
yo tampoco no queremos vivir en una
ciudad violenta agresiva no queremos
vivir en una ciudad que nos discrimina
queremos vivir en ciudades donde los
espacios públicos realmente son espacios
de encuentro son espacios de convivencia
queremos vivir en una ciudad donde
podemos tenemos donde todos hombres y
mujeres podemos movilizarnos tranquilos
y seguros y donde tenemos la misma
capacidad de elegir libremente nuestras
opciones sin tener miedo y yo como
sabrán soy una fan de las ciudades estoy
convencida de que las ciudades son el
espacio principal de la transformación
social porque las ciudades son donde
vivimos donde realizamos nuestros sueños
donde nos desarrollamos y las relaciones
humanas son tan importantes para
nosotros yo creo que los humanos somos
eso somos relaciones humanas nos
desarrollamos alrededor de tener
nuestras relaciones humanas pero no sólo
esas interacciones que son con nuestros
más cercanos no con la familia en el
trabajo con los amigos sino también